okay so the obi-wan kenobi trailer has a
lot of people talking about the return
of you mcgregor however he isn't the
obi-wan people are discussing and
alongside him there's a lot of hype for
the grand inquisitor who's making his
live-action debut in the show though he
looks like some eggs in the fridge and
shout out to jedi knight on twitter for
that one he's actually one of the most
fearsome characters in the star wars
universe but what are his hopes his
dreams well in this video that's what
we're going to be breaking down at
lightspeed and throughout it i'll be
going over his origins powers and a lot
more if you enjoy it then please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns like this
every day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
grand inquisitor
[Music]
the key
to hunting jedi
is patience
okay so up until now the grand
inquisitor has very much remained in the
expanded lore like the animated shows
comics and games seeing him in live
action is a major turning point for the
inquisitors and though people are
complaining about the costume look i'm
still very hyped for their arrival in
case you don't know inquisitors are
basically jedi hunting force sensitive
soldiers that scour the galaxy looking
for remnants of the order they're all
extremely tragic figures and at one
point most of them were either jedi or
padawans themselves between the events
of revenge of the sith and a new hope
darth vader built up a group of them and
he enhanced their abilities by teaching
them the ways of the dark side typically
sith always come in two with there being
a master and an apprentice however nice
little loophole here you can actually
have as many as you want as long as you
call them inquisitors now the most
impactful appearance they've had for me
was during jedi fall in order if you've
played the game then you'll know that we
open with cal kestes a lying low on the
planet bracket after he saves someone by
using the force they're alerted to his
presence and i very much feel like the
obi-wan show might be in the same vein
cal was a downtrodden worker much like
what we see with old ben and i think
that he'll have to use the force at some
point which will alert them it looks
like along with inquisitor riva and
brother 5 that the grand inquisitor 2
travels to tatooine and this is where i
think he'll be looking for obi-wan
however there are a number of other
avenues that they could be going now it
is possible that they've just been sent
to tatooine to intimidate those that
live there whereas the jedi were
peacekeepers these were peacemakers and
by that i mean they'll kill any man
woman and child to make sure that the
piece is kept look a public hanging yay
beyond that though the inquisitors were
assembled together after the emperor
sensed a new threat rising and this came
in the form of children who slowly
started to tap into their abilities the
teaser shows us the young luke skywalker
and not only is the de-aging by
lucasfilm getting better and better and
better it also shows us that he might be
the next target
[Music]
stay hidden
owen laws makes a big impact in the
trailer and though he says very little i
think that the guy will be protecting
his nephew the comics had a big section
where he basically refused obi-wan to
even be allowed near luke because of the
danger that he could pose now we know
that this show will actually take place
10 years after the events of revenge of
the sith and pretty much all the jedi
have been dwindled down to very low
numbers obi-wan will likely have to
weigh up whether to go near look or not
knowing that if he does it will put him
in trouble now because of the low
numbers of the jedi i actually think
that we'll see a lot of things from the
perspective of the inquisitors judging
by the teaser we'll even be visiting
their fortress at some point this
actually appeared as the final level in
fallen order and it exists not only as a
structure that dominates the surface but
it also has massive facilities under the
sea the grand inquisitor himself made
his debut in the star wars rebels
premiere titled spark of the rebellion
he was actually voiced by jason isaacs
aka lucius malfoy who always makes for
an intimidating villain however for this
show he's gonna be played by a rupert
friend but he's not your friend he's the
foe you've gotta look out for because
the guy is a really brutal actor friend
played agent 47 in the second hitman
movie and he's definitely got that
encaged side to his personality that i
think will work really well with the
inquisitor the character himself is a
poor and male that was recruited by the
emperor invader to track down any
potential threats that could come from
the emerging jedi in the rebels show
this came in the form of ezra bridger a
young kid that we watch mature over the
seasons as he comes to grips with his
powers later on in season two we
actually found out that the grand
inquisitor used to work as a temple god
on core ascent after the fall of the
order he was embraced by vader and
though rebels didn't show them
interacting all that much i think that
the series will expand upon this we know
from the sizzle reel that vader has a
hologram chat with someone from his
palace on mustafar and it's likely that
this will be the grand inquisitor he
actually had hologram chats with him in
the mini series so i am expecting a lot
of exchanges like that to happen as you
can guess from this he's ranked way
above the other inquisitors including
fifth brother sixth brother seven sister
eighth brother and ninth sister there's
also inquisitor riva who'll be appearing
in the show though we don't know her
full denomination yet you probably do
though as there's much smaller people
watching these videos than the person
making them so if they have if they've
put a number out yet just drop it in the
comments below and i won't get mad now
he also wields a double-bladed
lightsaber with a circular handle which
most of the inquisitors also carry you
can actually catch one on the back of
them in the teaser and when held in the
middle the blades spin around in a
helicopter motion during the new look
the ground inquisitor does some amazing
baton twirling at one point which means
you'll be busting out this technique
that i'm gonna be calling the thanos
before you start as well yeah i know
these guys did it first i don't want
your comments yet i know i said before
one of them but i don't want them yet
don't lose your [ __ ] mate sit down and
have a drink with your old buddy kevin
spoilers now the series had him going
toe to toe with ezra and kane and jaurus
the two of which were master and
apprentice now because of this and the
way that the show plays out we actually
know what happens to the character after
the events of obi-wan on his hunt he
managed to capture jairus and the rest
of kanan's crew ended up infiltrating
grand moff talk in star destroyer in
order to save him things went to [ __ ]
and it led to the villain facing off
against not only kanan but also ezra too
during the battle it seemed the
inquisitor actually killed ezra and this
spurred on kanan even more to finally
beat him the grand inquisitor tried
bursting out the thanos which kanan used
to his advantage he placed his and
ezra's lightsabers in the middle and
burst up the handle which made the
blades plummet over the edge this caused
the chain reaction and the grand
inquisitor held onto the side of a ledge
at this point he hinted there was some
fates worse than death and allowed
himself to plummet into the fire caused
by the explosion this is a very
ambiguous statement but we can take from
it that he would have rather perished
than have to deal with vader and the
repercussions of his failings let's be
honest yeah guys the worst boss in the
world now though it seemed like he had
died it was revealed later on that in
some ways he was still alive darth vader
trapped his spirit on tempest and here
he served as a guardian for the jedi
outpost that existed on the planet luke
skywalker ended up coming across him and
this all played out in the comics the
pair jeweled and luke managed to beat
him and he left the temple behind vader
arrived after sensing his son on the
planet and here the inquisitor asked if
his spirit could finally be released guy
was like bro yeah can i can i leave here
mate don't really like being here and
vader was like nah i think you can just
stay here mate you're kid so this is the
fate that was worse than death however
there's actually something that's much
much worse than that and in real life
the guy was actually a villain in star
wars angry birds too which
makes you realize how lucky you are all
in all though i can't wait to see what
the character gets up to and i think
he's a great aspect of the show yeah the
costume looks a bit wonky but hey it's
all in the performance and let the guy
live yeah seems like a nice guy in that
his last name's friend how bad can he be
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the character the
inquisitors in general and what you
think of the costumes let me know if
you're hyped if you're not and basically
anything you want to say to help push me
into the algorithm so i can make enough
money to buy my own lightsaber i was
lying about lying about the comments i
love reading them now if you want
something else to watch then on screen
right now we have our breakdown of the
obi-wan trailer or something else as
equally as terrible which youtube will
have selected for you you know what
though mate i hope you have a great day
and i'll see you on the next one you
take care of yourself and may the force
be with you i love you peace